right now the entire economy is shifted
the last century was a century about
power and when I say power I mean like
energy the wealthiest individuals of the
last century were built on oil the
biggest companies were all energy
companies fast forward today four out of
the top five biggest companies in the
world are not built on the old oil but
the new oil and the oil of today is
attention the thing that is being pumped
and drilled every day is the attention
of the masses you have 24 hours a day
that your ears are open and so the idea
is how can we capture as many of those
hours from as many people as possible
and the war for our minds the total
amount of attention that exists is every
human's eyes and ears collectively 24
hours a day that is the pie and they're
fighting for it people who are creating
the platforms that other companies can
come and drill they're basically the
digital landscape they've enveloped the
world they're literally buying up the
real estate of the collective attention
that exists the oil tycoons had to go
and buy a state negotiate haggle with
the farmer to get his things the new
world today hey they don't need to
haggle with anyone they just take it hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
how to get rich in the new economy enjoy
scarce resources are the things that are
the most valuable and so oil was the
scarce resource and now attention is the
scarce resource and so that's why
attention is the new oil a friend of
mine Ryan Fisher just showed me a clip
on his phone a podcast that I did with
him this is when I wasn't really
actually I didn't do any podcast I was
that wasn't doing any speaking stuff
like all I was doing was building gym
launcher Prestige Labs I was like screw
content just run ads I don't want to be
known I want to be rich and unknown it's
funny because he was like and now you're
not doing that I was very against it and
then what happened Kylie made the front
of Forbes as a billionaire and she was
20. and at the time I was 27 and I think
I had taken home 17 million in income
the year before I was on Pace to do like
13 to 15 that next year in terms of take
home and I thought like I was hot and
then this girl is seven years younger
than me crushes me in net worth and I
was like Wow and so it was just this
huge belief shift for me where I was
like what am I doing wrong my ego felt
hurt so I started protecting myself and
I was like oh no Kris Jenner is her mom
she's an absolute gangster she was born
into this royalty it's not that she did
it it was someone else and blah blah ego
protected I feel okay now and then Huda
Beauty sold a percentage of her thing
for 600 million at the time it's worth
over a billion today Conor McGregor came
out with proper 12 and 12 months later
boom it was a 600 million dollar deal
robots well and then the rock had
taramana tequila which is now worth like
four billion just kept seeing this again
and again and again to the point where I
was like I believe something that's not
true and so I talk about how skills
beliefs character traits are the three
things that hold back entrepreneurs and
this one for me was something that I
believed about the world and I was
functioning as though and it was not I
was trying to find those things because
they construct our reality and we make
our decisions based on the things that
we believe to be true and so I basically
was walking through a reality that was
not real I then read a book mine of all
ravacot which is his Almanac which is
really good really quick read and you
talked about the four types of Leverage
in the book Leverage is the difference
between what you put in and what you get
out the people who make the most money
are the ones who have the most leverage
because everybody's the same amount of
time it's just who gets the most back
for their time and compounding is that
now that you've made that trade with
your Leverage is it going to compound
unto itself and get you even more back
because compounding is a form of
Leverage and you've got labor you get
other people to do stuff for you which
means you get more of your time back and
you get output above that you've got
Capital so people give you money you
invest the money that other people give
you and you get Leverage by extension
the last two levels are code so you got
software and media so if you think about
this you make a piece of code and then
10 million people can use it that's
leverage you put one-time investment you
get infinite on the other side with
media it's the same way if I take
however much time it takes me to make
this video one person a million people
100 million people can see this video
which is what gives it leverage but when
I saw that that was what made everything
click for me as to why these people were
giving these crazy crazy numbers when
they had like I had heard Kylie had a
team of seven and she was doing 200
million a year I was like team of seven
and it was because she had a compounding
leveraged vehicle built within her
business and that was when I looked at
my own businesses at the time and
realized I had nothing that compounded
nothing I almost became dissatisfied
with the business that I had because I
realized that whatever I wanted to do
next I wanted to have a compounding
vehicle something that multiplies unto
itself over and over again so Warren
Buffett could build Berkshire Hathaway
because the money itself compounds and
compounds and compounds and on a long
enough time Horizon when you keep
rolling the snowball all after you do
that for 40 50 years you have a big
snowball you have to unlock one of those
four types of Leverage and so when I
looked at that pyramid I was like well I
understand the leverage of Labor so I've
got that I'm now in a position where I
have Capital that I can deploy now I
don't have other people's Capital
because that's not what I want to do
with my life right now but when I looked
at software and media I was like given
my skills Etc I could be better at the
media side than I could at the code side
but I still wasn't there yet I looked at
these people that are Ultra famous and I
was like huh well I'd still rather be
anonymous because they've got all these
stalkers and Weirdos hey good morning
oh when you get exposed to 10 million
people if you figure one percent of
people are crazy you got a hundred
thousand weirdos anyways I go to have
dinner with a friend of mine uh Dean
graciosi who's he gets like weirdos that
come to his house and all that kind of
stuff and I was like how do you deal
with this I was like why do you think
this like how is this worth it he just
had me down he was like
dude if if a couple weird letters
you know every day or every week is the
price I have to pay for the impact I
want to have he's like I pay that price
any day of the week and twice on Sunday
and there was just like this pause when
he said it between when he said it and
he looked at me and I just felt like it
hit me because I was like God I'm being
such a pansy I want to make real
business education available to everyone
if I say that that's what I actually
want to do then I need to match my
actions to that otherwise they're just
empty words I hate doing something that
I don't get credit for later and so the
idea of making a short that is going to
float today and then disappear into the
ether tomorrow right or make a post on
Instagram that's going to be gone in a
week like no one's ever going to see it
again to me taking the scarce races of
my time and then having it vanish I
couldn't make that work for me it was a
huge belief that I realized the content
is not the output is the input
the output is the audience and the
audience is what compounds the audience
is what sticks you're Gathering the
scarce resource and the audience is the
thing that pumps attention over and over
again you've got Mr Beast I think he
opened up a restaurant in a local area
and had 10 000 people show up at a local
restaurant I don't think people realize
that he's 24 and media compounds I will
make a prediction that he will be a
sense of billionaire not just a
billionaire but a sense a billionaire
and so becoming a master of media is a
huge way of creating leverage because if
Kylie can just point or Mr Beast can
just point and then you have a hundred
million people who buy anything
you have a billion dollar plus company
rule number two is fix your poor
financial habits with Kevin O'Leary what
we're going to talk about today
is really financial habits habits
everybody's got to do before they're 30.
now these are pretty simple but I get
asked this stuff all the time all the
time number one this is the top of the
Hit Parade you gotta stop buying crap
that you don't need and there's a reason
for this everybody is programmed Society
programs you advertise this program you
everybody's programming you to spend
money that's how the whole society works
that that's what capital is all about
I mean you know the whole idea of
consumer goods and services that you
need more of this stuff that you go into
credit to buy this stuff that's all bad
bottom line
one of the biggest spending on it is
clothing you buy so much crap you don't
need and it just sits in the closet for
years until you give it to somebody for
free you wasted that dope and when I say
that it's because if you take that money
and this is like an age-old theme you
take that money and you basically don't
save it saving makes you nothing because
you get paid nothing in a bank you
invest it you're taking this money that
you didn't waste by buying another pair
of jeans and other pair of sneakers a
five dollar coffee no no no no no no no
no I've said that before that's a total
waste of dough you start saving like
five bucks a day 10 bucks a day 50 bucks
a week you'd be amazed over your career
how much that's worth as it compounds at
six seven eight percent a year so that's
number one you absolutely have to be
very careful about that makes no sense
now before I get this going
what you want to do is pay off your
credit card debt I can't tell you how
you get screwed on credit card interest
17 18 19 20 21 percent
don't get sucked into that don't let
that happen to you I can't make 18 in
the market
and be guaranteed it like a credit card
gets it and charging you on your
interest that's why I own all the credit
companies stocks because they're doing
it for me but don't let me make money
off you that's dumb basically pay off
your credit card debt before you do
anything else because it's the best
investment you could have
such high interest rate all right now
another discipline and this is an earned
attribute in other words you have to
learn how to do this and stick true to
it you take 10 percent
of your paycheck
every two weeks ten percent whatever it
is after tax whatever you got
and you stick it into your Robo app the
one that's investing automatically for
you doesn't have to complicate it
download it from any one of these Robo
apps right on your phone set it up to
your bank account where basically your
paycheck's often deposited and take ten
percent force yourself to do that that's
after you've paid off the credit card
debt right
because that's the one you're guaranteed
to make 21 because you're paying off
something that's charging you 21 you
want to do that and this whole idea of
this 10 is not into the savings account
just gonna have some cash around you
need to have some cash
generally 90 days worth of your living
expenses is a nice little Safety Net in
case of catastrophe but
you start investing you get indexed into
the market that's what it's called and
you get a basket of stocks and it works
for you really really important these
are not complicated things to do it's
the discipline of doing them it's so
hard saving 10 every week once you get
in the groove and you start to watch how
your money grows right on your phone
that's interesting really interesting
paying off your credit card debt painful
but very important because you know
you're getting screwed crap I've said
don't buy crap 15 times now because I
want to drill it into your head don't
buy crap
don't buy crap don't buy crap don't buy
crap you don't need crap have that
little self on your shoulder I'll go on
your shoulder pretend it's me saying
don't buy that crap don't buy that crap
don't buy that crap you don't need to
buy that crap and that's how you're
going to save a ton of money let's talk
a little bit about investing in yourself
you know what what does that mean this
might be something that you know you're
reluctant to do but like they say you
got to spend money to make money it's
true well you have to invest in yourself
there's a lot of benefits to investing
in yourself as well as many potential
ways to invest in yourself that's true
do you have a skill you need to learn
maybe improve or master
the difference investing in the right
tools or classes can make this huge in
other words you go to school for
yourself you find something you like to
do maybe it's going to be a side hustle
maybe it's something you do at night but
you'll learn about it right now if you
could do digital marketing that's pretty
hot in the economy right now because
digital 2.0 is sweeping the nation all
these companies big and small are trying
to figure out how to sell direct to
Consumers well those skill sets are
understand the algorithms in social
media
photography video editing storytelling
web design digital imagery animation all
these things used to be oh that was a
purvey of the starving artist
starving the artist remember that
they're not starving anymore because it
turns out that all of these skills are
really important in the new 2.0 America
that came out of the pandemic so these
skills can be learned sometimes just
trained or online lessons or even go to
college at night these things college is
going to open up this fall you may want
to try this stuff and learn these skills
in addition to the job you have it's
like a side hustle nothing wrong with it
can be very very useful that's the whole
idea you know applying a new scale every
few months you know every few years
you know you don't really have years to
waste that's why you want to invest now
and learn something
now let me tell you another story I
think you're going to find interesting
you know me from Shark Tank right
listen to what I'm saying here
I've been doing it for 13 years when
those people come in the Shark Tank
they're sitting right in front of me I
should say standing they're standing
right in front of me and what you don't
know is that at the beginning of their
pitch we've got a jib like a camera that
flies in from the sky on this big jib
and there's also a guy on what's called
a Steadicam which is a camera attached
to his body that he can walk around and
it's got a stabilizing device in it and
that's that famous shot you see of the
entrepreneur standing there and then
their product behind them that jib shot
and that Steadicam shot are the setup to
the whole presentation they haven't set
a word yet and the floor director says
them don't say anything just stand there
while we get these shots sometimes it
takes a minute sometimes it takes two
minutes well
let me tell you what I do I'm right in
front of them sitting in that chair you
know I'm like this
I look them right in the eye
I don't blink I don't stare away I just
look at them
just like this don't look away
you can see me do it if you look closely
I don't stop looking
why am I doing this
I want to see what happens
and I'll tell you something I've learned
I've done it thousands of times
thousands of times
I can tell right that
from the aura
the vibe
you haven't even said a word yet and I
know right there if you're a winner
or a loser
and I'm never wrong ever
you haven't even said a word yet in your
pitch and I know whether you're going to
walk out of there with a million dollars
or something or nothing
how do I do that
it's in the eyes
how do you project confidence it's how
you look and how you feel and how you
project it right out of your eyes you
only get one chance in your life to make
a first impression
and you have to elude confidence even
though you're nervous sure you're in the
Shark Tank the first time you're
probably sweating bullets but you want
to elude confidence you want to look
right back in the eye stare right back
and basically say to me with your eyes
I'm ready to rumble you want to rock
bring it on that's confidence that's
what matters you have to do that every
day of your life
you're going to have situations for the
rest of your life when you walk in a
room and nobody knows who you are how do
you look how do you feel how do you
project that confidence
that's what it takes rule number three
is believe in what you're selling with
Gary vaynerchuk you go into kind of the
personal brand space that also there's
products kind of associated with your
name so whether it's empty wines or the
the K-Swiss you know sneaker line what's
most important to you when you're taking
a product and you're putting your name
on it
that I believe in what I'm selling
yeah you know I think I've been a great
salesman my whole life because I don't
sell things that I don't believe in you
know I believe that empathy wines is a
dramatically better 20 wine than most 20
Wines in the market I know that because
I know the sources of the grapes and
things that nature but I also think that
Maggie who I adore is sitting here she
may like a seven dollar wine better than
empathy that's okay
you know but I think to see and this is
actually like I'll be honest with you
this is actually where I've had a little
bit of I don't have a whole lot of
problems with the people in the industry
right even though we were like Renegades
and people would Razz me I always
understood but the one thing that did
always bother me is
you know after four glasses of wine
mainly Rose at can a lot of these people
who would publicly post nasty things
about me or Razz me in meetings would
kind of get just Tipsy enough to say
you're on to something or you're right
and I would ask them it was always
that's always so nice so I'm incredibly
I try to be remarkably gracious in those
moments
because I think all the things that have
worked for me is the byproduct of my
parents and the luck of my DNA draw so I
don't get too high on my garyvee Supply
I I say to them I'm like why are you
selling something you don't believe in
and I know the answer people have lives
and they have this is what where they
find themselves and they have mortgages
and kids like you know you know I get it
but there's so many people that could be
doing other things outside of Madison
Avenue now with us I think there'll be a
lot of copycatting of us in the next
decade so there'll be Alternatives but
like
you know what's most important to me
that I believe in it like I believe that
I am going to build
one of the most significant intellectual
properties of all time I really believe
that I really believe that practical
peacock can be like Lisa Simpson one day
I really believe that and so as you can
imagine that gives me the energy to go
so hard to believe like I'm really into
it and so you've got to believe in what
you you know I believe the case was
sneaker at that 40 price range is as
good of an alternative as another
sneaker and if you choose to like
believe in the mission statement of the
sneakers which is be kind be practical
you know if you see something in front
of you that you want it's going to take
work ethic not burning out but work
ethic you know and things like that so I
always believe in the stuff I sell the
garyvee stuff I believe that my mom is
the greatest Mom of all time I believe
that I believe other moms have come
along that tie my mom because they also
are 100 about their children but also
not delusional and keep it in this great
mix of like self-esteem building but
that entitlement building which is
impossible trust me I don't think I'm
good at it with my kit so I get it it's
hard
um so I believe in the things that I
talk about patience and kindness but I
do believe in tenacity and and
competition so I live in this world and
I'll use America I live in this world
that is desperately trying to make the
world about red or blue and every day
pushes more red or blue and I know the
answer is purple
right look at me I I as a marketing
proxy I think the Super Bowl is the
number one ad in marketing the best ad
you can buy
right even though I'm very anti-other
television
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is stop saving
fake money with Robert Kiyosaki I wrote
this book for my generation because the
baby boom Generations are toast
you know part of this are going to do a
fake pensions where my generation is
toast is that they actually believe
there's a pension
so this thing is fake money fake
teachers fake assets
it all sticks starts with fake money
so in 1971 the U.S dollar became fake
and uh this book starts with me flying
Behind Enemy Lines in 1972 I was a
marine pilot and I was looking for real
money gold
so this book starts to me flying Behind
Enemy Lines looking for gold because
when Nixon took the dollar off the gold
standard in 781 he made it illegal he
also made it illegal for Americans to
own gold imagine that was a criminal
offense to own gold I didn't know what
gold was
so I fly Behind Enemy Alliance I made
this little woman the Vietnamese woman
she got bright red teeth that she would
be a little nuts there and I tried to
get a discount on gold so gold back in
71 was 35 an ounce it was now about 50
an ounce in 782 so it was going up yeah
yeah so I said I think I'll buy some
gold
trouble is
I didn't know what call it was
most Americans don't know what gold is
because I've never seen it because they
made it illegal for Americans to own
gold and we know if everything fake
that's tragic so it's fake money only
reason fake money can persist because
you have to have fake teachers
what do our schools teach us about money
nothing
and we buy these fake assets stocks
bonds mutual funds ETFs and we save fake
money
that's why I wrote fake anyway but also
in Rich Dad Poor Dad lesson number one
is the rich don't work for money because
money's fake that's why yeah yeah it's
honestly I think it's very it's an
important lesson for all of us because
we're taught to save all this fake money
when you worked in a bank right yeah and
I worked at the bank so I see how real
this issue is when in reality it's not
going to help us when the day comes that
we need to be able to provide for
ourselves because how long can this fake
money last there's three kinds of money
today that you guys got to be aware of
one is God's money and God's money is
gold and silver so this is silver
and this is gold the reason I brought it
most people don't know what it looks
like
and then there's government money which
is fiat currency which is the dollar the
Yen the peso the Euro the Yuan yeah
fake and everybody's working hard for it
it's like eating fake food or drinking
fake water that's why people are getting
sick financially because they're working
for fake money yeah okay
and um then there's fake assets which
was another part of the fake Millennial
the fake generation series
but the reason I brought this here is
most people haven't seen it this here is
real silver Plata okay
that's what it looks like and so in 1972
And this here is gold yeah
this is God's money this is what God's
money looks like yeah the reason I call
it God's money is you can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake ETF
like a gold ETF or a silver which I
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys that printed that crap
you know what I mean Jesus
but this is real money so
you look at this here
when I first started buying that that
was a dollar forty yeah
yeah today that's 16 dollars
and this here is auto gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touched this is
real this is God's money why did I say
it's God's money because he was here
when the Earth was created yeah and
it'll be here when we're all dead and
gone when you're saving those fake
dollars this will still be here yeah or
those fake ETFs or those fake stocks
so this here is called the grain box
these are there's 500 of these little
tubes like this wow 500 coins in here
and this is one which is worth more
which ones with more
the gold yeah this is worth more than
all that now the reason I say this is
because for your generation
this could be the biggest opportunity
you'll ever see I'm not making any
commissions on this stuff yeah of course
but if you look at what happened with
the fake Central Bank so the purpose of
the central bank or the fed or all you
know the Japanese the bank of Japan or
the European Central Bank they pump out
fake money the purpose of central banks
like the FED is to protect the banks not
you
there are criminal operation as far as
I'm concerned
you're going to find that most of my
talks about the Fed
so I would recommend you guys buy this
stuff don't save money
don't save government money because
they're corrupt as hell as you know
save God's money so this is God's money
this is auto gold so today that's a spot
today is around sixteen hundred dollars
U.S now this is the difference
is gold more expensive in Mexico or in
America in America huh in America more
expensive in Mexico
if you live in a country like Argentina
it's more expensive because the price of
spot price is relative to the currency
of the country
so the people I was just in Argentina if
they had saved this they'd be okay today
but they saved pesos the same as a
Mexico okay same as in Peru yeah so this
is relative to government money
so this is about fifteen sixteen hundred
dollars today US Dollars and this here
is sixteen dollars it's about a hundred
times difference whatever it is I'm not
good at math but I'd rather have this
so you look at why silver could be the
best investment of all look at what's
happening
sober demand is getting higher
okay
silver fabrication demand in China is at
record high you look at look at this
whole thing in 2008 2009 2010 2011 it
never stopped even the world economy
near never nearly crashed demand for
silver kept going up because silver is
an industrial metal it's used in
industry this thing is only saved yeah
okay so in 1972 when I was flying Behind
Enemy Lines I bought my first gold coin
in Hong Kong it was a Krugerrand South
African crew Grant cost me 50 bucks
today that same coin is worth about
fifteen hundred dollars that no it's
worth about eighteen hundred dollars now
under the Kruger when get bigger
or the the dollar get worthless the
dollar got worthless yeah and they tell
you to save money yeah at the bank yeah
and I mean people are saving at extreme
amounts because they they want to be
able to protect themselves for when they
retire and things like that but it
doesn't make sense because the dollar
keeps going down and down and how many
currencies have gone extinct so really
what I was learning the other day is
that the dollar is basically coming to
an end of its experiment time and it's
gonna we might even go back to a gold
standard you know I doubt it yeah the
reason we won't go back to those gold
standard because because the banks can't
rip us off if we went back to the gold
standard of the Central Bank the fed the
European Central Bank bank of Japan Bank
of China they couldn't rip us off it's
not convenient so the whole thing here
is I'm not angry at my Banks because
that's where I got my money from I just
don't save my money there I save God's
money okay so this is demand for silver
it keeps getting higher
look at this a global government silver
inventories
is going down so what's happening is the
inventories of this is going up because
China is buying it Russia's buying it
turkeys buying it everybody's buying
gold now the potential banks are
they don't tell you that in school
though of course not rule number five is
become recession-proof with Dean
graziosi there is a quote I hear you say
a lot from Tony Robbins which is in the
winter people some people freeze and
other people Ski and Snowboard yeah so
my question is what is the mindset that
allows somebody to snowboard instead of
freeze I think to start its preparation
and anticipation rather than reaction
right Wayne Gretzky I love that quote
it's been overplayed but it said how is
he so good at playing hockey he said
most people skate to where the puck is I
learned to skate to where the puck was
going
if we anticipate and know you know so
many people we both know been in
business for 15 years or less they
really don't understand it so they're
more scared of the unknown and if you're
a study of history you can understand
it's a cycle it's happening and winter
is here I don't I think winter is here
we just all haven't felt the effects yet
and when you go through a time like that
the reason Tony and I are working
together and and doing events and
helping people is because
there's some Industries like you said
that are gonna they're gonna be at the
springtime they're going to
exponentially grow and if you saw Warren
Buffett in his yearly presentation I
don't know if you saw it probably four
weeks ago he said inflation is here
and where every session is inevitable
and there's a couple of things you can
do to thrive during a recession during
inflation and he said one of them the
most important thing is be a part of an
industry or start a business
that has high margins so the reason Tony
and I are sharing so much and I'm so
passionate about this because I've been
in this industry for 25 years is how
cool would it be to have a business that
you don't need to inventory you don't
need to ship it you don't have to worry
about supply chain it's probably one of
the most valuable assets you have
valuable that you own it and other
people want it you could sell it over
and over again with a limited Supply I
know that's what I'm saying and what it
is is selling information it's selling
your experience that's what Tony's been
doing for 40 years I've been doing for
25. you think about it how much has
information or learning from other
people impacted you in your life I know
what I know what to study you are yeah
and it's it's such a valuable asset and
it's not just us anymore right four
years ago the industry and let's call it
the self-education industry the
influencer industry the the upskill
industry
selling knowledge four years ago is
about a hundred million dollar a day
industry a day a day right now it's a
billion a day it's about 340 billion
dollar a year industry and I just read
this weekend it's heading towards a
trillion dollars by 2028. a day or a
year a year two the trillion will be a
year right now it's at a billion a day
about 340 billion dollars a year and why
that is is I don't think people have
time for general education anymore they
want specialized knowledge so instead of
going back to school instead of trying
to learn on their own they're saying hey
who's already been there how I'm already
built a business look what he did with
Quest what will Tom share with me and
how can I pay Tom to extract that or if
I mean we've helped people in 4 500
different niches whether it's going
through a divorce going vegan doing yoga
better or finding self-love again or
healing through trauma somebody has been
through that experience
and the world is seeing that they can
find a way to unlock it share it impact
others and create success and I think in
a time of recession whether it's the
self-education industry but it's
definitely a time you must investigate
because it is scary I was in business in
09 I was in when the world shifted I was
in business in 07 kind way of saying it
when the when the world shifted I mean
it was and it was brutal for a lot of
people
um and I know that sounds almost uh
insensitive to say some people starve
and some people skeet but I think the
foundation is we must get our mindset
right we must prepare and say it's
coming you can't make it worse than it
is and you can't make it better than it
is we must face the reality it's coming
and like Winston Churchill said those
that don't understand the past are bound
to repeat it so learn about it what's
happening prepare emotionally to be more
of that I feel like I'm saying too many
silly things but they're sticking my
head is be more of the thermostat of
life rather than the thermometer address
it but then it's time to investigate and
say where can I where can I sell
something that does that has higher
margins how can I impact others and how
can I you know thrive in this shifting
world and I think that's why we're kind
of pounding the pavement right now
because it's it's a time for everybody
to either start a self-education
industry bolt it onto your current
business
or at least explore and see if it's
something for you and rule number six
the last time before some very special
bonus Clips is scale up your competency
level with Brendan burchard long-term
wealth requires ever increasing
competency what you know now won't get
you there
you're gonna have to get new knowledge
skill ability and talent to go to the
next level
even if you luck into a ton of money
you're gonna have to get more competent
on what to do with the money right
dealing with finances is a skill that
you can learn
well same thing in every other area of
your life what I tell you all the time
ago show me where you make money
go what show me where you make money
what do you do to make money
and they go oh well you know I have this
job or I have this type of business okay
what's the skill there that you have
that you think is driving
[Music]
your pay
what's the primary if you had to narrow
it down to one two or three skills it's
driving your primary pay
and if you enjoy that skill
go deeper
gain more Mastery take classes watch
videos for free on YouTube
investing in your skill development and
investment means time energy money
effort
right time energy money effort
we gotta go okay
I I gotta I gotta put something in here
um
what's worthwhile investing in I'm like
yourself and your skill sets you know I
went to a bunch of seminars on how to
enhance my public speaking
I invested in hiring coaches in that
regard I invested in taking classes
and tutorials on how to operate all this
gear by myself I invested in
um online courses to learn how to do
online courses like these are skills
that you can develop and as you learn to
develop more skills it's easier to
exceed expectations and add new value
right I think skill development is way
underrated way under what we have now is
we have a browsing based culture versus
a Mastery driven culture
when you switch from I'm a browser right
I'm going to use this phone
all day like this
and I'm going to input a million random
things that mean nothing to me
whatsoever two I'm going to use this
thing to deeply study something that
will give develop my skill my
capabilities so I can build better serve
better lead better change add value when
this becomes a tool of study
versus just selfies or distraction
now you're on the right path of wealth
now you're on the right path to wealth
this is so important
I would say one of the fundamental
problems in our culture right now
worldwide is that most people invest
their time
in consumerism shopping
or an entertainment
just absorbing taking it in
and very few in active development of
skill
and skill can be communication
Conflict Management negotiation
leadership influence like soft skills or
hard skills like coding
like building something like designing
like creating something like actually
executing a process or behavior like
athleticism like something where you're
just developing that over and over the
Mastery mindset
is a path to wealth
the Mastery mindset is a path to wealth
when we invest in our skill development
over a period of time we're more capable
of adding new value exceeding
expectations going to the next level and
as we go to the next level in those
areas we tend to get paid more
that's important
once the primary drivers of how you get
paid today what are the major skills how
can develop them get way better at them
way better at them I had to learn that
in every area from online marketing
to email marketing to influencing to
teaching to running the gear to running
the company to how to deal with
employees to how to build up the
finances of a company like I don't know
how to do any of that coming out of a
broke mining town
but what I said is I want to be able to
serve at the highest levels so what
skills do I need to learn
when I was an author and I was broke I
said what skills do I need to learn okay
well one skill for me is writing a book
so I'm going to study how to write well
so I studied and studied and studied how
to write well great that's one skill
though isn't it and I'd look at these
other authors I said well how are they
so rich
how are they wealthy
well it turned out a lot of them were on
the road speaking
and as they spoke more people bought
more books and I was like well that's a
virtuous Loop okay so if I can learn to
become a teacher and a speaker
then people buy more books well I want
to be a writer who sustains My Life as a
writer that was my goal okay I guess I
could add that skill
which would support the finances over
here
it was an adjacent skill
that served the main goal for me
okay well I hate speaking
I don't like it but I was like well why
don't I like it well because I don't
know how to do it I'm uncomfortable
doing it well I was uncomfortable riding
a bike I didn't know how to do that well
let me try let me put some training
wheels on let me learn to speak so I
started speaking and teaching myself
time energy investment of my heart and
my soul to speak and I was literally
speaking to myself in a room walking
around wearing out my carpet just
teaching myself to talk out loud about
topics for long periods of time you know
it's like okay figure out how to do that
then I was like okay I need to get in
some practice I need to get in front of
some audiences so I'd start doing it in
classes I'd volunteer to give my report
out or when it was time to get a report
out I'd put some flourish on it man and
I just thought okay I'm gonna keep
getting better I'm gonna keep trying to
get in front of more and more audiences
and bigger and bigger I'll speak free I
don't care I just need to run the Reps
to gain the skill so I can become good
at it because I saw speaking as an
adjacent way to serve people Beyond just
my writing
so that was an entire skill that I built
up from scratch with no natural Talent
OR ability in fact more fear
and so I was like okay but that's going
to serve over here let me see if I can
do it and let me see if I enjoy it and
of course once I got over the fears and
I saw the impact beyond me
with people
I was like wow that really made a
difference in person's life who might
not read my book wow this
is just another vehicle for me to make
my difference
I thought it had to be about book
writing I was like oh but I can make a
difference this way too
huh and I can enjoy this too huh
and if I hadn't done that we wouldn't
even be here right now
if I hadn't learned to run a camera by
myself because I'm in a room by myself I
don't like this is I'm literally this is
a real room I'm I'm here by myself
running all this gear like it's just me
and so I had to figure out like how do I
do that how do I do the lighting right
before we began literally with the team
we were adjusting the camera and they're
watching on Zoom I'm like how about here
how that what do you think about that
like trying to figure out all these
little things without knocking
everything down
and if I hadn't learned that we wouldn't
be here
so I would also say I wouldn't reached
the scale
in my own career as you scale up your
competencies you scale up the likelihood
you will build wealth
you must visualize the steps that lead
you
to the thing that you want
not the end goal this is a major mistake
that people make they manifest
improperly because all they do is focus
on the end goal if you've ever made a
vision board think about what you put on
the vision board you put up just the
beach house or the million dollars in
the bank or you crossing the Finish Line
are you launching that business are you
having the body that you want or you
would drive in the Maserati whatever it
is the end goal is what you put up on a
vision board that is not what you're
going to do when you manifest if you
start focusing on crossing the finish
line of the marathon that is a one-way
ticket to being unmotivated and
completely discouraged in fact research
shows that if all you do is focus on the
thing that you want and you just focus
on that vision of you and your bikini
body or you with the love of your life
on your arms or you at the Oscars
winning that award or the Grammys
what happens is because you've only
focused on the end goal you start to
feel really unmotivated and discouraged
because you're nowhere near it that's
where manifesting comes in because we're
not going to focus on the end goal you
gotta pick something that you want in
order to get started but manifesting
isn't about the end it's about the
bridge
it's about going from where you are here
to where you want to go
imagine that there is a bridge
that connects where you are right here
with what you dream about doing
now that dream could be to be a Grammy
award-winning
singer-songwriter that dream might be to
have a family of your own that dream
might be to have a beach house or a ski
house or to take a trip to Fiji that
dream can be whatever the hell you want
it to be but when it comes to
manifesting once you've given yourself
permission to dream with the lid off and
really want what you want to feel the
pull of that thing now we gotta talk
about the path that connects where you
are with where you want to go and this
is all about visualizing the Little
Steps there's a lot of research that
proves why visualizing the steps is the
most important thing that you could do
there was a study done at UCLA for
example where they were researching
manifestation and the power of
visualization and they broke students
into two groups and they had group a
we're going to call these the vision
board group they had group a closed
their eyes visualize in their mind and
feel in their body
themselves taking the test and then
walking up to a board where the tests
scores were posted and finding their
name and seeing an A plus that's what
group a the vision board group we're
told to do to visualize themselves
achieving what they wanted
Group B
we're going to call these the hard
workers these students were coached in
this research project to close their
eyes and to visualize going back to
their dorm room sitting down at the desk
and studying and staying up late and
putting in the work studying and
preparing for the tests
now let me ask you a question
which group do you think did better on
the actual test
was it group a the vision board group
who were taught to visualize and picture
themselves walking up to a board and
seeing the a plus
or was it Group B
the hard work group the group that was
taught to close their eyes and visualize
and seeing themselves doing the work to
study for the test
well if you answered group a you're
wrong
if you answered Group B you got the
correct answer the reason why Group B
the students who visualize studying for
the test got better test scores is
because when you visualize yourself
doing the work visualizing it leads you
to doing the work and it's only through
actions that you will get the result
that you want preparing your mind and
visualizing yourself doing it lowers
your resistance and leads to you taking
the action that's why manifesting works
you know the same is true in sports
there's all kinds of research in sports
psychology in fact our Olympic athletes
for the U.S Olympic team they hire
Sports psychologists to train our top
Olympic athletes particularly after
they've been injured in visualizing
themselves competing when you coach an
athlete to mentally rehearse every
single detail about going through the
competition you are training the mind
body and spirit to show up and dominate
this is is particularly true for
athletes after they've been injured and
they're stepping back into competition
if you've been injured in competition
you're naturally going to feel anxious
you're naturally going to be nervous
your brain and nervous system circuitry
is now programmed with the intensity
from that injury the memory from the
injury so of course it's natural to
bring that in to your pre-competition
feelings about it right so manifestation
properly remember what it is manifesting
is preparing your mind body and spirit
to do the work it's aligning your mind
body and spirit with what you want it
removes the obstacles that would
normally stop you which then prepares
and motivates you to take the actions to
succeed so in the case of athletes who
visualize themselves and see themselves
doing all the steps over and over
they're removing the nerves they're
removing all the programming related to
the injury they are prepared their mind
body and spirit to go in and freaking
Dominate and so are you you speak about
the concept of the Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's
there's I would say what we mean by soul
is something like animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say what a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read in all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest gestation
and if you think children can't do that
well then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the father person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net to
score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating in that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminologies like well until
you come up with a better word there's
plenty of use for it because it's a very
complex and deep phenomena and to you
know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if they're free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth if you want to
have more money one way is to uncover
the areas where you may be wasting money
and that's why we're talking about five
common ways we throw money away where
exactly did your money go money is
something a lot of us struggle with
check this out in a 2019 employee survey
a PWC 71 of Millennials said their money
stress had gone up over the past year it
is stressing me out and nearly half of
all respondents said that they spend
three hours or more every week thinking
about or trying to sort out their
finances and money woes don't just
affect us individually 44 of young
adults said that the money is the number
one stressor in their relationship I
mean the borrow some money and check out
these stats according to Erin Lowry
creator of the broke Millennial Blog the
average Millennial graduated with 37 000
in student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks Productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and a place to start is to
stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
sus Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested The 100 more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
rough retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have I hope you're sitting
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have 60 760
dollars and 41 cents I'm gonna sit down
and that's just with basic compounding
interest okay so here's another big way
we raise money buying new now here's the
thing I know for lots of us I'll be
honest myself included how we look is
important we enjoy fashion but you can
continue to have your unique look and
have favorite Brands and still spend
less money on clothing here's a way to
do that I have another friend who's into
designer Brands but would never pay
designer prices her secret is to shop at
consignment stores and now that there
are lots of these stores online there
are tons of items to choose from and you
can even shop by your favorite Brands
the other month I complimented my friend
on a sweater and she told me she's got
it for 65 less than the original price
and it came brand new with the tag still
attached plus shopping Consignment also
benefits the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff Beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to for
example if your iPhone breaks you can
actually buy a refurbished one directly
from Apple for way less money and they
come with a warranty and don't get me
started on cars here's another quiz when
you drive a new car off the lot it
literally immediately loses a certain
percentage of its value what percentage
is it a five percent B 10 or C 30 the
answer is B according to Carfax the
second you drive a new car off the lot
it loses at least 10 percent in value
over the first year it loses about 20 of
its value that means if you spend thirty
thousand dollars on a brand new car
within a year it's worth only twenty
four thousand dollars and the value just
keeps going down instead of needing
everything brand new look at what you
can buy used or borrow from someone you
know and that's another way we waste
money we buy things immediately we think
of it we get all excited we go online
and buy it it's like when the Apple
watch first came out and I went out and
bought one I was so stoked but no
offense to the product I discovered
pretty quickly just in time to give it
back that I didn't actually need it I
ended up returning it
take it back instead of impulse buying
Bachelor purchases if you say oh I need
to buy that whatever it may be and then
go to Amazon and buy it and then later
in the day or I wanted to get some of
that other thing I loved and then going
to Amazon or another store to buy that
what happens when you get your card
statement it all adds up and you're like
whoa how did I spend that much money I
don't remember any of that and that's
because fifteen dollars here and ten
dollars there doesn't seem like much of
the time especially when you're using a
credit card or other digital payment but
you don't see the money you don't feel
it you don't actually have that
experience of giving it away or holding
on to it instead when you think of
something you need and I'm putting need
in quotes because it might not be a real
need but a want put it in your cart and
leave it there or write it down on a
list don't buy it right away then at
some specified time like the end of the
week look at your list all your carts
and choose what it is you really need
that will give you a better idea of what
you're actually spending and what you
actually need versus what you want
another way we waste money is by passing
up free money a court and you're and
you're wondering what are you talking
about according to investment advisors
Financial engines American employees
leave roughly 24 billion dollars on the
table every year in unclaimed money by
not taking full advantage of their
employer match on their 401K the typical
employee loses out a 1
336 dollars per year now look if your
boss said hey we'd like to just give you
1 336 dollars per year you'd be like yes
please right I'm gonna need that in cash
but if you're not contributing the full
percentage that an employer will match
you're basically saying No thank you so
you need to stop missing out on free
money when I analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back
over there on my on my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage you need
to learn how to either develop products
you need to learn some of the technology
needs that you have there's a lot of
different hats that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do you'd have to find how
do I get somebody who could do the
surgery so for those of you who are not
good at marketing or sales which is the
oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done when you see an
opportunity what do you do when you've
got an idea that you know could be great
that comes to your mind but then your
inner voice starts taking over to say
you can't do that you're crazy that's
never going to happen What do you do
it's in these moments that your entire
self-identity is created because for too
many of us we've created the identity
that
we get great ideas but because we don't
know how they're going to work out we
don't know how they make logical sense
we don't we don't take any action on
them and that's how you lead to life of
regret
that's how you lead to life that in 10
years you look back and you say I wish I
did something why didn't I do anything
how many times have you had a great idea
that you thought was a great idea then
you see somebody else go off and make
tons of money off of your idea
the only difference is they started it
and you didn't you know it's not that
they're any smarter than you or more
resources you probably have more heart
more more Vision more purpose than they
did so why are they successful and
you're still sitting here because they
did something on it while you're
thinking about it researching it
planning it strategizing it reading
about it they went off and did it that's
the only difference it's the courage to
stand up and say yes and take action on
the imperfect idea
so
I look at um
Adam Duran is an example I did an
Instagram live yesterday and Adam Duran
came in and Adam Duran was a guy an
entrepreneur who I met in San Jose and I
knew he was coming to my event I was
doing my tour
and the day before
I'm in San Jose they perform a big event
I see Adam Duran go live
on Instagram
I'm at an ice cream shop I go to the car
we're eating our ice cream in the car
and Adam Durango is live and for
whatever reason I come up with the idea
of I I should I should go see what
Adam's during is doing live
I don't know why
but let's go do it and I go and join us
live and there's you know two or three
people in it not a lot and so I said I'm
going to join the item live
I'm going to join Adam live
and so he invited me in
and then my audience starts funneling in
so now he has a bigger audience of
people who are watching
and while I'm sitting there talking to
him
my events the next day I say Adam I just
got this idea
I'd love for you to introduce me to
borrow at my event
somebody local you're from San Jose it's
all San Jose Ian's come and introduce me
and he said yes
I never had anybody introduce me at my
events I don't even know this guy yet
right I mean I just hung out with him a
little bit on Instagram live I don't
know who he is I don't know if he's
gonna suck I don't know what he's gonna
say and in his mind is all the fears and
insecurities of oh my God it's tomorrow
I don't have a month to prepare this
what am I going to say I mean I don't
want to disappoint Evan or let him down
as easily tons of fears on both sides
but he said yes I asked he said yes and
he came the next day and he was so
nervous and he you know got all dressed
up when he brought a cameraman along
with him as well and he crushed he did a
fantastic job
the point of that story is
trust your ideas
to trust the things that come into your
mind to trust that they're good to trust
that they will serve you to trust that
they're the right things for you to stop
judging your ideas to stop to stop
trying to be practical all the time with
the ideas that come to your mind because
your brain is designed to keep you safe
your brain is
understanding of what currently exists
so it doesn't understand the new things
that could be where your heart can come
up with brand new things that's why you
always make the big decisions in life
with your heart and the small ones with
your head
because your brain will will talk you
down from it
so in that story with Adam there are a
couple key Moments One was deciding to
join Adam's live on Instagram
why did I come up with that idea I don't
know I signed her live I said okay I'm
gonna go join him
then when I'm talking to him asking him
to come and introduce me even though it
wasn't part of my model even though
nobody was introducing me at other
events even though I didn't know who
this guy was really
but something felt right and so instead
of judging and overthinking like there
was no time to judge and overthink
because the event was tomorrow
this idea came to me I'm gonna trust it
I'm going to say yes
and then same thing on Adam's side
he didn't have time to overthink and
judge it he could have said no he could
have said I'm not ready he could have
said who me he could have said he could
have said I'm not ready
and instead he said yes
we were both afraid we both said yes and
it ended up being great and that helped
Adam and he's gone on and done a whole
bunch of other videos and speaking and
he's amazing
is that was a that was a big moment for
him we were talking about it yesterday
the more you can teach yourself to go
from idea to action
is where great things start to happen
the first thing that most people do when
you come up with a great idea
is we default into research mode we
default into planning mode and while
we're using our courageous energy
our bold energy get an idea you get
excited right you get an idea you're
bold you're courageous you want to you
want to go do something like yeah just
be amazing
we waste our best energy
on planning and researching and
strategizing and and talking to a friend
instead of actually doing something
about it
with the best thing you can do is to
take imperfect action
so you go from idea to action idea to
action you gotta you got an idea default
to thinking default the training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea it's amazing how about we start
thinking you have Amazing Ideas how
about that how about that being the
default way of thinking instead of
thinking oh this will never work I suck
I'm not good enough I don't have the
resources this is too difficult I'll
never be able to do it how about we
start to switch the default narrative in
our minds that you come up with amazing
ideas that the fact that you came up
with it means it's a good idea and you
should do something about it it doesn't
mean you go mortgage your home to go
start this thing
[Music]
but it's a good idea
step number one right your ideas are
good step number two is
take imperfect action don't go mortgage
to home don't go making some big plan
don't don't start thinking about how you
need Venture Capital to start this thing
what's the what's the first smallest
dumbest step you could take today just
to do it
just to do it just to start you want to
start YouTube channel awesome take out
your phone right now I'm filming what
I'm filming this video in my parking
garage right now you know Tuesdays I
filmed the content Nina usually does
some errands and I sit in the car and
film content she finished her errands
early I still have a video to make so
I'm going to finish his video sitting in
the parking lot of my condo
is this perfect no is the lighting good
no I'm still here filming content you
can do it
what's the first step you want to make a
YouTube channel pull out your phone
today make a piece of content you want
to write a book go write your first
three pages
like it's just taking I call it the two
percent difference you have your goal
that's getting 100 whatever your goal
your mission your vision reaching that
will be 100 completion of your goal
right perfect don't worry about 100 yet
what we default to doing is planning the
100 don't worry about that yet focus on
the first two percent what's the two
percent difference what's the first two
percent the first two percent is making
your first video the first two percent
is writing those three pages the first
two percent is going to the gym today
the first two percent is is going for a
walk the first two percent is recording
your first song or the first two percent
is just anything to build momentum don't
worry about how it all fits into the the
grand scheme it's going to feel like you
don't have the plan the problem is you
spend so much time on the plant that you
never start doing you spend your best
energy on creating the plan and then you
wake up the next day and you realize I
can't do that who did I think I was
yesterday thinking I could go do that
you haven't built any momentum and then
you freeze and you stop and this is how
you end up going through this cycle of
of great ideas and then no momentum and
then another great idea and then no
momentum because your best energy is
spent on planning instead of doing so
the two percent difference gets you out
of it and you're going to feel out of
control you're gonna feel like you don't
know where this is going you're going I
feel like there is no plan perfect
perfect the plan will come plan tomorrow
today is action two percent difference
so step number one trust that your ideas
are great they came to you so they're
great you're a genius stop telling
yourself that your ideas suck they're
great you got to do something on it set
number two is a two percent difference
we're taking immediate action on it and
then step number three is just expect to
suck expect to suck why do you expect to
be great the first time out when you
first picked up a skill as a kid you
first got on a bike you first got on a
pair of skates or rollerblades what
happened you fell down it's normal
why do you expect your first video to be
amazing why do you expect your first
page of the first draft of your book to
be awesome it's not it's going to suck
expect to suck expect it to suck
what we often do is internalize that and
say well because it sucked therefore I
suck no that's not what it means you you
rock
because your first video sucked doesn't
mean that you suck as a human it means
you're amazing for trying if your first
video is amazing then I think you suck
because it means you should have started
it five years ago your first of anything
needs to suck
we have these impossible
standards for ourselves that we say well
I need to be great out of the gate or
I'm not going to do it and then you get
stuck in in the never creation mode
expect it to be terrible it's it's okay
it's normal that's how great things
happen is your first thing sucks your
first trip to the gym will suck your
first push-up will suck your first video
will suck your first page will suck your
first song will suck all of it great
that means you're amazing and
that's how progress happens that's how
you start to move forward on your goals
because you don't want to stay stuck
just knowing that you could have done
something but you're too afraid so step
number one trust that your ideas are
good they came to you therefore they're
good step number two the two percent
difference immediate action and then
step number three expect to suck that's
how you start to make the transition
that's how you start to live that life
that you want to live
you've had amazing dreams and goals in
the past that didn't come true
not because you're not capable just
because you didn't take action
use that as leverage as fuel going
forward because right now you've got
great ideas too right now you've got a
great heart too right now you know that
you can be doing something
epic
and all that's missing is momentum
all that's missing is your willingness
to be courageous to expect to suck
and then to create
and next they create again and next they
create again and next you create again
you do that every day your life will
look dramatically different one year
from today
you're a genius you've got an amazing
heart the only thing missing from the
life you want to live is momentum
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
seven steps rich people take for massive
success check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I think
of this idea of performance necessity
two stories kind of come to mind one is
I was working with an Olympic gold
medalist Sprinter and we're in the
tunnel and we're going out and he's
talking about the competition